du gehst du ich gehe zum fusion dies mit
bis zum frittieren jetzt geht's um
versichern dass die menge passieren
hh er ist stabiler irgendwo leute ich
weiß dass reactions auf diesem kanal uns
sehr gut gefallen deswegen gehen wir
heute mal auf eine sache mit ich bisher
noch gar nichts zu tun hatte ich hab
mein bruder max zur verstärkung mit
dabei und wir schauen uns heute die
geissens an
hast du schon jemals eine folge von die
geissens geschafft nicht wirklich glaube
ich auch ich hab hier führt über
investor von den geissens gefunden die
folgen sind ein bisschen älter deswegen
ist die qualität so ein bisschen so lala
aber ich würde sagen wir starten also
direkt keine einzige fähre kriegen also
das glaube ich so das glaube ich dass
diese machen in diesem in dieser sendung
er spielt jetzt golf von seiner jacht
aus kann man mal machen und hat gerade
versucht diese fähre davon zu erwischen
ich hab mir grad ebenso ein artikel
durchgelesen ich glaube dass dahinter
ist dass er irgendwann so ein
bekleidungsunternehmen hatte und das
irgendwie verkauft hat und ja jetzt
schießt er also er liegt mit seinem boot
im hafen und versucht jetzt läuft also
tatsächlich hier aus so einer fähre
leuten zu schließen
[Musik]
ich glaube das ist so was man machte man
leuten so wirklich zeigen will dass man
halt das ist halt sagen wir so das
normale leben verlassen hatten wenn du
wirklich dann zeigen wir ganz ehrlich
ihr habt also normalen job und so ne ich
hab so normales leben
damit habe ich nichts zu tun weil ich
schlage golfbälle von einem boot auf ein
boot aber bescheiden von ihnen
eigentlich das hat aber im hafen liegen
bleibt und nicht irgendwie dennoch den
weg zum tor das wäre dann die nächste
stufe dann so also wenn er denkt so dass
die leute immer noch meinen er hätte
noch normales leben er war noch normaler
mensch dann sagt man dem kapitän euf
ernähren die jagd ran
ich verstehe den weg dass ich dir auf
jeden fall erfolgt sind zwar nicht der
beste golfer abschlagen kann er auch
also insofern kann ich das risiko ganz
gut einschätzen ob man das vom dach vom
boot aus machen kann oder nicht und auch
keine angst vor kratzern die iren vom
dach entstehen also die sag es mal keine
fällt dazu sagen so unser vater hat auch
so ein kleines boot stelle mal vor wir
würden eigentliches thema vor der würde
uns einen schluss zu die burg geben
und hier kommt zurück in den hafen und
eines tages stehen wir beide auf dem
dach von dem hof durchzuschlagen der
golfbälle was würde passieren
er würde im körper aus der luft fangen
und werfen wir uns ertrinken kommst du
den ganzen tag hier weiter
aber das muss man feiern auf jeden der
sowieso dass der wirt sowie der
personifizierte flex wisst ihr was
flexen ist leute so angeben also wenn
flexen ein mensch wäre wenn wir sie ja
auch gerade also die erste minute von
einem sieben minuten best auch von der
ganzen sendung dreht sie durch umkehr
golf bild vom boot das schiff muss los
bruder und ich glaube seine frau isst du
bist noch das normale mr
ich glaube auch er sich zeit vor allem
da können wir uns ja gerade schon gehört
robert ja das kommt natürlich einerseits
kann man das feiern andererseits muss
man auch deutschlands oder für bisschen
passen unsere prominenten sind ja das
ist ja mal cool dass da mal so richtig
endstufe alle ich kenne ja die ganzen
haufen leute die meinen sie hätten eine
kleine cut wohnung beziehungsweise ein
kleines chaos und würden schon in der
endstufe leben
ok ja also es wirklich so der der flex
er ist so der flex vom dienst das ist
ein bisschen komisch
das ist ja schön und gut wenn jemand
sich irgendwie so luxus leisten kann und
so aber muss man zu den leuten dass die
nase rein das war schon ein bisschen
kraft an seid also dieses golfspiel
verbot habe ich noch gefeiert das
geilste machen aber euer leben ist halt
scheiße so komm mal ein haus das größte
das wir gefühl also ich glaube jetzt
immer kurz vor der endstufe das denn
schon maße wer will nicht schon mal in
seinem leben einmal eine insel besitzen
oder will nicht ohne insel besitzen ist
es ein gedanke durch den kopf gehen
packt man wo es eigentlich eine insel
für diese nein sagen aber ich habe
bisher noch nie darüber nach das muss
ich ehrlich gesagt das ist ein ziel was
man isst jeder will sein leben allein
sie besitzen nein die gans nicht ich bin
bescheiden leute lassen aber bei mir ja
irgendwie ist ein nachbar da irgendwas
haben verbrennen wer aber auch keinen
[ __ ] dadurch könnte es doch genau an
einem tag machen wo der wind in die
andere richtung steht deshalb habe ich
die nachbarn ja auch weit weg wenn du
das grundstück anguckt das ist halt so
das problem was man hat mir zum landsitz
irgendwo am mittelmeer verbrennt der
nachbar holz steht dann ist entweder
rauch über also dann wird es ganz
ehrlich einfach das haus auch noch
kaufen von dem nachbarn also zwischen
zwölf und drei made man auch kein rasen
was macht man nach 3 uhr wenn jeder
seine siesta vorbei hat oder um macht's
vor 12 uhr
ich fange ich auch nicht morgens um 7
uhr an wenn presthofer motto arbeiten
okay stimmt ja also ist wichtig weil die
leute müssen sich auch irgendwo von
millionär sein erholen können
also zwischen zwölf und drei ist pause
da ist eine stunde du bist ja schon von
acht bis zwölf schon millionär ist sogar
im schlaf millionäre rund um die uhr der
bomber bisschen erholung fort aufs
gymnasium geht muss dann auch noch ein
bisschen rum studieren und weiter bis
sie ganz schnell 56 27
wenn ich die bundeswehr der einzige
bisher 30 und man kann bei gartner geld
verdienen da war ich schon fertig ok
also der flex geht intensiv weiter
wiso-tipp mathiebe dazu gelesen das
bekleidungsunternehmen jahren 1400
fitness klamotten hergestellten oder für
die bodybuilding szene damals freund
also ich finde halt wenn man auch in so
einer position fest also nicht mal so
ehrlich sein soll ist es mega geil so
man will das hat euro zeigen denke ich
mal aber also als gehört eigentlich auch
in jedem geschäft bisschen glück mit der
zone
dass du genau in dem moment so die
bodybuilding szene in deutschland groß
wird dann so ein unternehmen macht sowas
macht man dann so tun als hätte man
keine ahnung krebs geheilt von monaco
an dem pool auf eine geile nummer also
würde ich mir kaufen
ja das hat auch so eine alltagssituation
die wir auf jeden fall kennen wenn man
wieder so ein heli verbreitet und längst
egal wo ist wobei ist eigentlich meinen
oder es wird allerhöchste zeit wo ist
meine insel wo ist meine heli insel auch
bei dior oder chanel schätzen
der rücken schmerzt weder und braucht
kein mensch
ich glaube das ist auch so sein
lebensinhalt also ich glaube dass einen
tag besteht aber so außen millionär sein
sich vom millionär sein erholen und
seine frau opfer hier sein dasein schaut
mal wie die beladen du siehst du das
hast du kein schlechtes gewissen nämlich
eigentlich so sind wird nicht war der
abend war aber andererseits wenn sie das
alles drauf für sich als echt so also er
war ja schon mit ihr dabei soll das noch
mal fragen
du gehst du ich geh zur person des
menschen nicht importieren ist geht zum
friseur dass die menge passieren
er ist stabiler er wurde für also das
recht gemischt teilweise habe das die
dinger raus und das ist wirklich einfach
kosten stabil so was ist zum beispiel
galt ja aber dann wieder so andere
autobahn a2 bis diese ihm schnell
aufgezählt luxus honig soll luxusyachten
luxuskarossen und nicht zu vergessen die
fluxus mittels frauen das sind luxus
frauen frauen ziemlich mieser kommentar
von rwe weiter wäre das einfach seine
ehefrau luxus frauen der das was ist
damit gemeint die als kritisch auch
nicht jeder wieder den ersten cl platz
anwohner urlaub gemacht hat insofern
muss ich mir nicht unbedingt die erste
wohnung angucken wo ich mal eingezogen
bin also also man könne jetzt nicht jede
station ab fahren wo wir mal gewohnt
haben dass nämlich das problem das darf
man nämlich auch nicht machen also wenn
man so in die richtung geht dass man
sich vom normalen leben verabschiedet
hatten davon auch nicht mit einem
solchen wo man bei einem normales leben
hat also es wird mir noch einmal ja dann
sonst denken die leute wirklich okay
dass das auch in normaler mensch erlebt
so ungefähr derselben ecke wie ich
feststellen da vielleicht irgendeine
beziehung dazu her zu der person das
geht nicht dass wieder ruhe und fast
läuft aber ich sage dir hat läuft über
das ist einfach manchmal desto stabiler
grad
das ist das ist einfach worum ging es
jetzt gerade hat sie sieht den song
gemacht hat sie würden sie den song
gezeigt wird sie vorgespielt haben ja
ich meine so gewisse den höheren na ja
auch dass fast überall ich das natürlich
am ende keinen kommentar geben so von
wegen robert robert last dass am ende
muss den weihnachtsmann geben das ding
hat geld gekostet aufgebaut werden damit
weihnachten stehen bruch und anderen
ganze woche führt er ist und was sie
jetzt einen riesigen aufblasbaren
weihnachtsmann gekauft offensichtlicher
warum sollte man so was tun sollte man
sowas kaufen
ja das ging es ja locker dass er locker
zehn meter großen das auch gelassen ist
oder wo sind die das sieht aus wie der
ort wo das windows xp europa aufgesucht
oder kanal wir sind irgendwo in den
alpen ich weiß es nicht denn jetzt
wieder oben auf dem balkon und kupfer
dann anbietet macht er galt wer zuvor
kommt ja das ist wieder so der teil von
nokia ist glaube ich nicht dass stabile
beratern ist inzwischen wieder voll
kacke weil ich habe gerade zwei neue
reifen kaufen haben wir mal wieder
irgendein buch mitgenommen wie ich
aussehe jetzt das passiert wenn man
versucht als millionär so normale dinge
zu machen wir sind normale menschen
machen einen autoreifen reparieren geht
nicht aber erfrischend zu sehen und
mensch also an den fundamentalen dingen
ich glaube mehr muss man zu dieser serie
nicht sagen sollte kommentierte unter
diesem video leute habt ihr diese
sendung geschaut hab mir die nicht
geschaut feierte die für die komisch das
ist so auch mal zu der ganzen sache und
natürlich an alle leute die die videos
gerne schauen aber den kanal noch nicht
abonniert haben ich würde mich freuen
wenn ihr abonniert und jetzt werden wir
hier drüben noch ein für euch persönlich
vorschlages video leute fürs zuschauen
bis zum nächsten mal